tant d'histoires d'amour sont formées à partir
de contes de fées et de la version idéaliste
de ce qu'est l'amour et de la façon dont deux personnes
devraient être ensemble, il y a des aspects de
cela dans le film, veuillez vous joindre à moi pour
accueillir mr.  Christian Grey Ana n'a jamais
vu quelqu'un comme ça elle n'a jamais vu
ces choses qui sont impressionnantes en ce moment
Christian Grey homme évidemment très
puissant sa flotte de voitures dont
une est à toi oh ce planeur dans son
hélicoptère et toutes les choses que
les gens normaux n'ont pas -  deux pour
Charlie Tango prêt à partir Roger que
Charlie Tango ce James Bond-esque
ainsi que ce garçon qui avait pensé que la mer d'
avoir toutes ces choses à votre disposition
pour pouvoir voir quelqu'un dans ce monde
est toujours une chose attrayante au départ
quand  il l'emmène dans l'hélicoptère et
quand il a de nouveaux vêtements qui l'
attendent le matin tu as l'air de belles
choses qui sont si réfléchies et aussi
décadentes oh mon dieu
c'est incroyable c'était important d'avoir les
livres de la première édition je ne peux pas les accepter  Je
dois les renvoyer et les cadeaux tout
au long d'accord, signez simplement ici, c'est
beau et incroyable mais écrasant
et finalement dénué de sens si la
relation ne peut pas fonctionner vous tous  eh bien
oui, faites-le publier
toutes les choses que Christian montre à
Anna Je veux dire que n'importe qui s'amuserait Anna
planeur
ce n'est pas à quel point il est riche ou à quel point
le style de vie est décadent, c'est le
fait qu'ils n'ont jamais aimé
quelqu'un autant qu'eux  vous aimez
ou vous attendiez-
vous